Вгадайте, що це? Їжа. Пластик. Добрива. Ця зелена машина може бути всім.
Ми на порозі революції!
Це навіть висмоктує СО2 з атмосфери і знижує рівень метану в коров'ячих відрижках.
І - найголовніше - цьому можна завдячувати - не більше-не менше - за життя на Землі.
Так що ж це таке?
Це водорості. Їм три з половиною мільярди років, а ми ще лише з'ясовуємо їхній потенціал.
Усе почалося давно, дуже давно. Земля була гарячою жижею, повною отруйних хімікатів. Ані тварин, ані рослин.
Синьо-зелені водорості, які ще називають ціанобактеріями, змінили все це.
Ціанобактерії - це одна з найцікавіших груп організмів. Вони дійсно захоплюючі.
Це Моріц Кох, мікробіолог, який вивчає саме цей вид водоростей.
Ми нині живемо у світі, в якому кисень в атмосфері в основному пояснюється так званою "кисневою катастрофою",
коли приблизно кілька мільярдів років тому ціанобактерії почали виробляти кисень і тим самим створили наш нинішній світ.
Ціанобактерії, або так звані мікроводорості, дуже-дуже маленькі.
Водночас те, що вимивається на пляжі, і те, що багато хто називає водоростями, це макроводорості.
Водорості насправді схожі на рослини в океані. І тому вони виконують ту саму функцію, що й рослини на суші, тобто фотосинтез.
Вони поглинають CO2 і перетворюють його за допомогою сонячного світла.
Це Мар Фернандес-Мендес. Вона експертка з морської екології, яка вивчає,
як водорості поглинають вуглець та впливають на весь морський харчовий ланцюг.
Коли водорості поглинають цей вуглець з океану, океан негайно поглинає вуглець з атмосфери,
оскільки цей процес перебуває у постійній рівновазі.
Тож якщо ви щось забираєте, це має знову додатися до атмосфери.
Щорічно океанічні водорості поглинають від чверті до третини світових викидів CO2.
Але це роблять всі водорості, навіть не океанічні. Тому незалежно від того, що саме це за водорості, їхнє вирощування затримує CO2.
Людство використовувало водорості впродовж тисяч років. Корінні народи - від Америки до Східної Азії - були першими водоростевими фермерами.
Водорості навіть згадувалися у найдавніших зразках японської поезії.
І навіть допомогли ірландцям пережити Великий Голод 1840-х років.
Сьогодні водоростева аквакультура найкраще розвинена в Азії, водорості становлять значну частину місцевої кухні.
Їх також використовують у зубній пасті, косметиці та ліках.
Вирощування водоростей для цих продуктів паралельно допомагає знизити рівень СО2, але це не є головною метою.
Втім, незабаром це має змінитися, оскільки використання водоростей як корму для тварин, добрив та біопластику
також зменшуватиме обсяг викидів від "брудних" галузей промисловості.
Тож отримаємо подвійний ефект.
Поговорімо про пластик. Деякі водорості природним чином містять і виробляють біопластик.
Він може замінити поліпропілен, другий за поширеністю вид пластику.
Моріц та інші науковці модифікували синьо-зелені мікроводорості - ціанобактерії, щоб виробляти більше біопластику.
Використовуючи методи метаболічної інженерії, нам вдалося збільшити цю кількість з 10 до понад 80 відсотків.
Тож ми створили щось на кшталт бактерій з біопластику.
Цей біопластик з водоростей розпадається, як звичайний побутовий компост,
і не виділяє забруднюючих речовин у довкілля - на відміну від інших видів біопластику.
І вже є навіть інфраструктура для його виробництва.
По суті, можна використовувати наявні технології для виробництва різних ціанобактерій.
Не лише для виробництва харчових продуктів, але й біопластику.
Технологію аквакультури також можна використовувати для вирощування макроводоростей.
Один тип водоростей має воістину дивовижну властивість:
Коли Asparagopsis taxiformis додається до корму для тварин, він зменшує виділення метану з худоби на 82%!
Під час травлення в шлунку худоби виробляється метан, який тварини згодом випускають.
Складові цих водоростей, схоже, перешкоджають утворенню газу.
Стартап Symbrosia - нині у центрі уваги ЗМІ. Він експериментує з виробництвом кормів з водоростей для худоби.
Але велике питання стосується масштабів застосування технології, адже ці водорості потрібно спочатку виростити.
Однак у деяких випадках водорості вже є. Наприклад, саргасум.
Його батьківщиною є Саргасове море. На його частку припадає 7% СО2, який поглинають усі океани.
Але через глобальне потепління та забруднення саргасум виходить з -під контролю.
Величезна кількість виходить на поверхню у Карибському басейні та Мексиканській затоці.
У 2018 році цвітіння вимірювалося у понад 20 мільйонів тонн.
Зазвичай водорості розпадаються, але зараз вони вимиваються на берег.
Крім жахливого запаху, вони забруднюють воду, вбивають тварин і руйнують корали.
За такої кількості ці килимки саргасуму - це по суті "зірки смерті".
Хорхе Вега Матос працює у C-Combinator - компанії, яка займається використанням саргасуму
для виготовлення екологічно чистих продуктів.
Одним з перспективних варіантів використання є добрива.
Ця сфера бере початок ще з часів Римської імперії.
Нині їх синтезують у екстракти для широкомасштабного використання.
Ми можемо перетворити його на різні сполуки, які використовують позакоренево, тобто розпилюють на саму рослину.
Також їх можна наносити безпосередньо на землю - або як рідину, або у дрібних гранулах.
Поживні речовини, що містяться в добриві, збагачують ґрунт і викликають у рослин процеси, що захищають їх від патогенів.
У результаті з'являється більше плодів, а також рослини стають стійкішими до стресу й хвороб.
Але найпростіший спосіб використання водоростей - поглинання CO2.
Водорості природним чином падають на дно океану, коли вони гинуть.
На дні океану зберігається CO2. Тож, можна пришвидшити цей процес.
Якщо ми хочемо збільшити кількість вуглецю, який нейтралізується, наприклад, саргасумом,
нам потрібно буде активно брати ці водорості, стискати їх та активно топити.
Це означає додавання ваги або використання насоса для відправки їх на дно океану.
Нещодавнє дослідження показало, що глобальні сільськогосподарські викиди можна нейтралізувати,
використовуючи 2% океану для вирощування та потоплення водоростей.
Чому ж людство цього досі не зробило?
Найбільш поширені макроводорості - ламінарію - нині лише прикріплюють до чогось.
У великих масштабах це вимагатиме великої інфраструктури. Ось де з'являється саргасум.
Якщо вам потрібні макроводорості, які можуть рости скрізь, плаваючи в океані, як фітопланктон,
але можуть поглинати цей вуглець з набагато більшою ефективністю, ніж фітопланктон, то ваш варіант - це саргасум.
Технологія збору саргасуму вже використовується у деяких районах, таких як Мексика.
І багато різних структур - від стартапу у Великобританії до уряду Мексики -  працюють над тим, щоб зробити його більш ефективним.
За цим повинні стежити не лише такі біологи, як я. Це те, за чим має спостерігати все суспільство.
Ось тільки поки бракує фінансування.
Тож поряд зі зростанням уваги до вирощування водоростей як кліматичного рішення
необхідно також посилити стимули для підтримки поглинання CO2.